if you could put one message out there
what would you want to say smart girls
are morning I love that walk about Scott
move meet Josh Smith and today we're
joined by the geniuses behind book smart
any to how many girls are gonna be up
your vagina not sure every time I come
to visit you you're gonna be scissoring
a different girl dude what this ring is
not a thing
don't knock it into the night go knock
it until you've tried it guys how are
you
oh good now first of all I just want to
say thank you so much for making this
movie because it's so incredible I mean
if I have this maybe growing up yes as a
gay boy and seeing like queer characters
represent in this way I'm like yes thank
you this is what I need this movie is
not a makeover movie which is right I
love so much I feel like there's so many
movies that I grew up on where the women
in the leading roles felt the need to
change something about themselves in
order to be accepted by their crush at
school or should just be accepted by
society and I feel like that was a
really big thing for yes-no assimilation
the desire needs no ponytail dad these
girls glasses on acne who they are this
they know how fun they are and how smart
they are yes they they have no shame in
it every character I related to growing
up like Lisa Simpson or Mathilda or
Hermione Granger who are all references
for for me and Caitlyn for this movie
they were alone they weren't with
another girl like even Hermione she has
two guy friends and I feel like to see
not one but two of these characters and
their lack of competition between them
in fact like they're aggressive
obsession with each other um would have
been really really meaningful for me
because what's amazing about were you
guys saying is it's kind of like me
where you go I can see you and I can see
what you're doing and this is
I see who you are was the person that
you watch er and not like a stereotype
of whoever basically yes can you
remember a time where someone said to
you I can see you
and how about changed well you know it's
funny I referenced it when we were
making the film but I had a very good
friend once day to me in a moment of
like crushing insecurity and doubt she
said to me have you met you and I
thought that's a really beautiful thing
for a friend to say like I want you to
see yourself the way I see you I want
you to value yourself and I felt very
seen by her and valued and filled with a
sense of confidence and support that I
was like this is why we need our friends
sometimes we completely lose perspective
on who we are and our value and you can
slip very quickly into this place of
just like oh I'm worthless and this
friends who tell you like I will not let
you degrade yourself I will not let you
minimize your skills and talents and
beauty and all the other things have you
met you because I will continue to
remind you who you are
[Laughter]
yes actors it's constantly constantly
growing up I was and I still obsessed
with musical theater and when you're
like chubby and you're obsessing musical
theater everyone's like have you played
Tracy Turnblad and hairspray and I was
like oh there are other roles like I
want to play the Baker so I pit into the
woods I want to play dots I mean the
park with George I was like I don't want
to play Tracy like I'm so much more than
just this surface judgement that your
your seeing me on so I remember very
early on being like oh screw that I'm so
much more than than just my body or just
one the sound of my voice you know
whatever it is it's such an important
thing to do because I think it's a long
we've spent so much time like especially
things like slut-shaming yes and like
films like this and director that young
audiences that kind of message was
sending out there to be like you can
make the choices you want for you and
having respect for that amongst your
community and I think that such an
amazing message you guys get across from
there
absolutely to Kirk just literally
talking about sex-positive feminism in a
film that is just extremely fun and
funny but there's there's language and
messages in there that hopefully are
lifting all genders up and all people to
allow themselves to be whatever they
want to be Janek I didn't need to be
preached to they're better they're just
better and smarter and they already know
all the things that now older people are
starting to embrace they're shouting
from the rooftops they are at the gates
saying this is our world now thanks for
messing it up move out of the way we
don't accept your paradigm we're
shifting it and this movie is honoring
that and saying like yes yes take it
away because it is a bit like with the
treatment unless being character for
instance yeah yeah exactly it's just
like it's because it's kind of like
within our generation I would say it's
like the sick thing you probably mention
about them yes let's talk about like
Amy's character bio and what that would
say her her sexuality would not be the
first or the second or third yeah there
would be so many other things about her
because in the her sexuality does not
define her also the fact that the only
love scene in our film is between two
girls and it encapsulates all of the
teenage sexuality is it's like nervous
and awkward and consensual and funny and
weird and beautiful and sexy and all
those things but telling that story of
teen sexuality through a queer yeah
scene is super radical because what
would you want to see this film changed
by the discussions around female
sexuality if you could set a long
message out there what do you want to
say I'm just removing all judgement
you see smart girls are warning I love
that these types of characters that are
like getting into Yale and present the
senior class and like you know changing
like you know yeah women in Botswana
like talking about masturbation and
yeah a normal way and yeah it was funny
we were shooting the scene where they
watched poor and it was so important to
me that we not see the porn it's not
about the poor and it's about the fact
that these girls are watching it and
genuinely turned on and we're not
judging them for it the shaming has to
stop and then the assumptions about if
you're horny you must be stupid or
unserious in some way all of it has to
stop
[Laughter]
[Music]